foreign
have you heard about the healing power
of bongo drums
it's not it's not a joke you'll see yes
ma'am is using his drumming skills to
promote healing and relaxation but his
weight look CBS New York same [__]
desk oh my God this desk company is
saying look at this [__] fast now
that's three places I want to be the
sales rep I want to be that sales rep at
the desk company [__] doing it may look
a bit strange at first CBS News Elijah
West were caught up with him and shows
us how his new technique is changing
lives both physically and spiritually
you're an anchor look look look at the
healing look at the healing mechanism
foreign
does your headache feel better I'm gonna
put you in an off-brand Amazon tent it's
not even a Coleman
is that first and then lay you on our on
an LGBT yoga mat and then bang
um The Bongo but it's wrapped there's a
cat toy tube wrapped around it
cool
interesting sight to see a man playing
that's not an LGBT rug you guys want it
because of the chakras yeah this is for
the chakras it's different a man playing
a bombard drum attached to this blue
tube inside a woman's legs are stretched
forward while her upper body bro speaks
will fall for anything [__] are so
[__] superstitious we are focused so
superstitious
did we just fall for anything that we
think is like magic
sits in clothes than this small pink
tent you may ask what's going on I did
the transition of vibration
that starts oh boy this this guy's just
a [__] scammer he's running a [__]
grift this is great bam the volume four
I mean it's brilliant and then he just
gets to hang out and play he probably
likes to just play the Bongos anyway
yeah look it was either this or [__]
playing him in a subway platform I was
thinking Mr Penn Station us
as the person lays there it starts from
their foot that's Jose Ortiz known as Dr
Drum who has the doctor is he a real
doctor is Doctor drum a real doctor is
technique down to a science it's called
a bomba healing he's like one of those
Dre kind of doctors yeah but he says
promotes a calming effect and one that
is reminiscent of a human heartbeat
look if your heart is doing that go to
the doctor
yeah that's not good frequency
that actually energizes
Louise Guzman [__] with us it might
be
[Music]
on this day Dr John performed on Staten
Island at the Anderson Neighborhood
Senior Center in Port Richmond he's
typically based in the Bronx but his
admired talents tend to pull him in
other neighborhoods the Puerto Rican
Belmont oh yeah Puerto Rican no way
a New York and running a scam
what
never heard of that Bronx native says
he's been drumming for more than 20
years but his overall it was that
[__] bad
look to be fair it's been muffled by
sneakers
Ashton for the instrument started back
on May 5th 1964. after he was hit by say
this I bet the food there is amazing
yeah no absolutely that I will agree
with are while running across the street
just to catch a glimpse of a group of
men playing Puerto Rican music is
literally banging on sticks let me be
clear here Virgie I don't respect any
Puerto Ricans okay I want to make sure
that we have that clear
bomb boss I don't know what it was but
the tones the tones I don't know what it
was Dr Drum Jose Ortiz the drums
really drew me this is the African
blueprint of alignment
oh well look he didn't mention that
earlier if I wouldn't know it was the
African blueprint of a lineman I
wouldn't be [__] arguing yeah because
I mean if there's one thing meant black
people this shock was really a lion oh
yeah [__] it
yeah I was I was looking at the crime
statistics I was chakra too
this is how I connect with rhythm and
how important rhythm is
flower body that firm belief is
resounding across the city while he
promotes this rare technique that others
and I just had to try
Saturday
hate CBS New York you know you have a
lot of problems going on in that city
right and you're doing a bongo segment
yeah I mean I don't think the Bongos are
really gonna help maybe uh I don't know
let the cops do their jobs yeah
satisfying electrifying it seemed like
the just with the tempo the drums it was
I could feel stimulated you know like my
legs and
oh okay wow
so she was saying that like that the
part of her body that that was in pain
yeah that she was getting relief what's
so exciting no no you [__] goddamn
specs are so stupid
you fall for anything God damn old white
ladies [__] he's an old white lady no
no no you know the one before the one
before Oh okay that's not sick it's a
lot of white people this one this one
this one yeah it's getting relief it's
so exciting he's probably in on it yeah
I enjoy music as it is so this was
fantastic who doesn't I love when people
say things that are so generic I hate
music
and all the colors not in my
neighborhood my buddy Jeff said that one
time to a chick who came over and sat
down and was talking to us and Jeff's
gay but uh I think the chick was trying
to hit on both of us
and like was talking to us and we were
trying to have a conversation and like
she was doing that thing where she just
asked you random questions and then
finally she just goes what kind of music
do you like and Jeff just looks at her
and he's like ah music's terrible
and it was one of the funniest I mean I
to this day will never forget that one
because it's like who would say that in
real life she's like Ugh this looks
terrible Dawning in a short sleeve white
lash shirt you see why he nicknames
himself Dr Drum a man who pairs music
all right but I want to see some
credentials doctor
much love to respect to Dr Jeremy brings
so much healing and joy I'm betting it
doesn't produce a calming effect on the
neighbors or the comments
I'll give Dr Drum credit he probably
gets more [__] than Dr Bass
yeah [__] seriously absolutely
especially more than Dr Road agent yes
um
foreign